i think they're going to be massively
surprised by the end of the show
i mean just
i think i really think people are going
to be like oh my god they're going to
look at the mcu in a whole new light and
also have a much
deeper understanding about
in what direction it's moving um i would
also say that you know
so many things get leaked and people
find out about certain things can i just
give them a little taste i wouldn't say
too much
but there's this thing that's been kept
completely under wraps that is
that happens and i work with this actor
that i have
always wanted to work with oh and
we have fireworks together and
uh the scenes are great and
uh i think people be really excited uh
i've always wanted to work
uh with this guy and
uh it's pretty the scenes are pretty
intense
how's it going everybody it's warren
welcome back to the cosmic wonder where
we talk all things marvel and
everything marvel cinematic universe and
the first three episodes of one division
were amazing but they
certainly were confusing and a lot of
fans are wondering when exactly are we
going to get answers well i have some
good news for you because it looks like
we're getting our answers pretty soon as
early on
as next episode episode 4. and as you
just heard paul bettany say we are in
for quite a ride as there is a mystery
character coming
pretty soon that i guess none of us are
expecting but that's not all we've
gotten recently from the marvel cast in
fact a few different cast members have
dropped a few different lines that give
us a little bit of an insight of what's
to come
in future episodes specifically
elizabeth olsen herself
mentioned episode 4 as a shift so for
those of you who are looking for
answers in the show you'll get some in
episode 4. so let's talk about what this
means in an interview with digital spy
elizabeth olsen said
when we started filming this show we had
all nine scripts so i didn't have to not
really know what was going on ever
it was very specific she goes on to say
i think the reason
why they show the press the first
episodes is because
episode 4 is quite a shift it's a really
fun perspective swap and i think a lot
gets
understood at that moment now this makes
a ton of sense now that they only showed
the press the first three episodes some
of you may know that i
actually got to see the first three
episodes myself before it came out but
it didn't really give much away
as all of you know now the press didn't
really know much more than the general
public did because nothing was really
revealed
but that is all going to change now for
everyone
elizabeth olsen says that episode 4 is
quite a
shift and a really fun perspective swap
and
she says a lot gets understood at that
moment now what many people
assume is going to happen here is we're
actually going to get a perspective
from shield or sword as they now are in
the marvel cinematic universe
and the reason that we think this is
because of trailers and tv spots we have
seen some scenes in trailers and tv
spots of events that already happened
but we didn't see the scenes in the show
for example we have seen the red
helicopter with the sword
symbol on it already appear within this
bubble reality in one division
however one of the trailers and tv spots
showed the helicopter getting sucked
into this energy bubble
this is something that we actually
didn't see in the actual episode which
means they are waiting to show us this
which means it's probably from the sword
agent's perspective who got sucked in
and that agent could even be monica
rambo or geraldine as she is referred to
in this universe
this could be how she ended up getting
inside of this reality this would make
even more sense considering the fact
that in the end of episode 3
spoilers if you haven't seen it yet she
ends up getting tossed out of the
reality or should i say forcefully
thrown
by wanda and the only thing we see is
her kind of breaking that shield barrier
and landing in a field
but in other trailers and tv spots we've
actually seen her get thrown
out of the reality we see her flying out
of wanda's house
up to the shield bubble and then
bursting out this is something we
haven't seen yet so that shift in
perspective
is probably going to go from wanda's
perspective
to swords perspective specifically most
likely
monica rambo and if that wasn't enough
the other actors of the cast are
promising answers next week as well
paul bettany even went as far to say as
i think next week will blow
your mind and tayonna paris who plays
monica rambo
in the series said i hope that you all
tune in and ride this thing with us
because it will be well worth it i know
there are so many questions in the first
couple of episodes and just no answers
but
we'll get to it i promise and hopefully
very soon we get to see this
mystery character the surprise guest
that paul bettany
is really really excited about could
this be mephisto
could it be the grim reaper at this
point we're unsure who this specific
guest is going to be but we are
excited to find out and it looks like we
are finally going to be getting some
answers
this week in episode four so let me know
all of your predictions on what is
actually happening
in one division in the comments down
below and don't forget to subscribe for
more breakdown videos and theory videos
of wanda vision and other
mcu content as well don't forget to like
the video and for live updates you can
always follow me on twitter and
instagram as always thank you all so
much for watching woof
you